welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Attack on Titan full series recap before
the final part 100 years ago the Titans
appeared they're naked creepy looking
man-eating Giants that hunted humans
almost to Extinction but some survivors
managed to build enormous walls so the
last remnants of humanity are all
trapped here and the walls work
extremely well they're way taller than
any Titans so for the last hundred years
Humanities had a relatively peaceful
happy existence but some people are not
happy like our main character Aaron
Yeager who hates that Humanity's penned
in here like cattle Aaron is a real
angry kid who likes to yell a lot his
best friend Armin is a smart kid who
likes to cry a lot and their other best
friend Mikasa is the strong silent type
who's there to keep Aaron in line one
day everything changes when an
absolutely massive Colossal Titan
appears this thing is taller than the
walls and it kicks open the gate letting
the Titans inside it is a Slaughter and
while Aaron and friends are carried to
safety his mother's left behind and
Aaron watches as his mom is devoured by
a Titan his hometown of shaganchana is
destroyed but it was on a little knobby
outside the walls with the Dual gate
system so the interior gate is still
intact until another abnormal Titan
appears this one an armored Titan and oh
it charges the gate boom burst It Wide
Open now the Titans are flooding into
Walmart yeah and the entire outer ring
the bulk of Humanity's Land Is Lost
Aaron Yeager valves Revenge he's going
to kill all the Titans every last one so
as soon as he's old enough Aaron joins
the military along with his best friends
Armin Mikasa and he meets some new best
friends among the other recruits there's
Connie who's bald Sasha who's hungry and
John who's kind of cocky becomes Aaron's
rival now the humans fight Titans in a
super cool way using odm gear
omnidirectional Mobility units that
shoot out grappling hooks and let them
fly around you gotta get up high because
the Titan's only weakness is at the nape
of their neck pretty soon Aaron's
training is almost complete but just
then the Colossal Titan appears again
but this time Aaron Jaeger is ready to
fight back he gets up there ready to
take this thing out but just as quickly
as it appeared it vanishes what is going
on here but before it left it destroyed
the gate so now Titans are pouring in
and it's up to our group of recruits to
fight them off it's time for their first
epic fight against the Titans but oh
Titans look kinda silly but they are way
faster and stronger it's not a fight
it's a massacre even our main character
Aaron oh gets his leg chomped Harmon's
about to be eaten well there he goes but
oh Aaron grabs him and gets him to
safety how's he gonna get out of this
one well he doesn't he's followed maybe
he's not the main character with Aaron
out of the picture his friend Mikasa
takes the spotlight she is by far the
best in the class she's a Titan killing
natural her parents were killed when she
was young it was actually Aaron who came
to save her but he failed and at this
moment something in her snapped she
understood that in this cruel world you
have to fight to survive so now mikusa
goes on a Titan killing Rampage until
her odm gear runs out of gas then things
are looking Bleak but wait what's this
one Titan Attacks the other and now it's
his turn for a Titan killing Rampage all
right when he's finally defeated
something very strange happens at the
nape of his neck is Aaron Jaeger what is
going on for reasons unknown Aaron
didn't die but burst free turning into a
Titan and not a Mindless Titan like the
others but one where he was in control
it might have something to do with his
father Grisha Yeager who five years ago
gave him a mysterious injection and the
key to a secret basement but that will
remain a mystery for the next 50
episodes now everyone is quite surprised
by Aaron's transformation ability but
this one smart guy command underpix is
recognized is the opportunity here Aaron
figures out he can transform by drawing
blood like biting himself so boom he's a
Titan again he grabs a big old Boulder
and uses it to plug the gate so this
time humanity has stood its ground so
now Aaron Yeager is giving over to
Commander Erwin of the Scout regiment
who's just a real smart good guy and
once they officially graduate all of
Aaron's friends joined the scouts too
the strongest of the scouts is Captain
Levi who is an absolute Titan killing
machine and the smartest of the scouts
is hanji who's the scientist type trying
to figure out what Titans even are so
pretty soon it's time for their first
mission into Titan country the scouts
are the best of the best anyone normal
Titans no big deal but today a new
abnormal Titan shows up the female Titan
and now that we know Aaron can do it
it's pretty obvious someone's driving
this thing she makes a beeline right to
Aaron trying to capture him but this
whole thing was a trap boom yeah they've
got her they had a suspicion there was a
spy in their ranks unfortunately she
does not stay trapped very long and goes
on a rampage killing all of Aaron's new
friends so now Aaron transforms two and
it's a Titan fight but she has the
ability to hard in certain parts of her
body and oh beats Aaron Handley Captain
Levi and mikasaki give it everything
they've got to get Aaron to safety now
one of their friends and fellow recruits
is Annie and I don't want to jump to
conclusions but she looks exactly like
the female Titan they lead her into a
trap but it doesn't work and she
transforms again it's Titan fight round
two this time in the city and this time
Aaron takes her down we might finally
get some answers but something
unexpected happens she hardens into a
crystal shell and that's where she stays
the rest of the series so in season two
our crew has earned some well-deserved
rest but Titans appear within the walls
but where did they even come from the
walls were not breached but now our gang
is surrounded within this time are Emir
and Krista amir's a real tough gal and
Chris is real nice and Amir has a huge
crush on Krista she's like hey girl I
love you sorry about this secret she
leaps off the tower and cuts herself yes
Emir can turn into a Titan too how many
people can turn into Titans what is
going on emir's Titan is a weird little
Gremlin one but she holds him off long
enough for reinforcements to arrive and
when she comes to hopefully we'll
finally get some answers we do solve one
mystery of where those Titans came from
it seems like they started at Connie's
Hometown and one of them still stuck
there and there's just no denying it
that Titan is gone he's mom yes it seems
that all Titans are people blah but how
and why was that Village transformed
well it might have something to do with
the new abnormal they saw a giant monkey
man Titan they named him the Beast Titan
but he didn't stick around more on him
later so now after their latest brush
with death our one friend Reina has had
enough he's like yo Aaron me and Bertolt
are undercover Titans on a secret
mission to capture you so just come with
us now and we'll stop all the fighting
um wait what yes our friend Reina is the
Armored Titan and bear tolte is the
Colossal Aaron's not going without a
fight so he and Ryan are doing some
naked Titan Jiu Jitsu while the rest of
the scouts try to take down Bertolt but
the colossals got a hot steam defense
mechanism they can't get closed
captioning not available
and by the way anyone with Titan powers
can regenerate any injury it'd be nice
if we finally got some answers on where
these two came from and what's going on
but they don't say nothing but when
Aaron yells at them for breaking the
wall and getting his mom eaten they seem
legitimately remorseful they were just
doing what they had to do they brought
him here with them too though she wasn't
with them and she's not saying much
either we do get a vague part of her
story for reasons unknown she was turned
into a Titan which was for many years a
waking nightmare but she stumbled upon
right on bertilton and he's undercover
crew and ate their fourth friend and
apparently if a normal Titan eats
someone who has a Titan transformation
power they turn back to human and now
get that power anyway the scouts catch
up to him so it's a big old Chase with a
bunch of normal Titans following
Commander airwinds leading the charge
but doe gets his arm bit off that
doesn't slow him down though in fact he
busts in to cut Aaron free but now Ryan
is chucking other Titans Adam it turns
into a whole mess and Aaron Yeager comes
face to face with the Titan that ain't
his mother he tries to transform but he
doesn't have the strength yet so he goes
to just punch this thing and oh it
actually works something unexpected has
happened for reasons unknown Aaron can
now control other Titans what is going
on so now the humans are able to escape
Amir says goodbye to Krista like hey
girl I love you but I think I should go
with them Aaron doesn't keep his Titan
controlling power it only worked out
once so once again we're left with more
questions than answers so season three
begins with an unresolved mystery from
the start of season two there are Titans
inside the walls the high priest of the
wall of religion seems to know something
about it at first he wasn't talking but
eventually he agrees to but now before
he can he dies under mysterious
circumstances smells like a government
cover-up indeed the powers that be have
decided the scouts are getting too close
to the truth so they have them all
arrested on trumped up trees and charges
so for a while our crews got to go into
hiding as fugitives and hunting them is
an incredibly skilled fighter it's Kenny
Kenny the Ripper he and his crew use odm
Gear with guns specifically trained to
fight other humans but there's still no
match Captain Levi Kenny himself though
is a match for Levi in fact Levi is his
nephew that he raised in the undercity
until one day he got bored and left
turns out Kenny and Levi are both
ackermans who for a long time were the
Bodyguards of the king something in
their genes make them incredibly strong
Fighters which is why they're so much
better than everyone else and guess who
else's last name is Ackerman it's Mikasa
yes it's not by chance to use that skill
it's in her blood so now the
government's going to execute Commander
Erwin and disband the scouts but the
rest of the military is like yeah nah
you guys are clearly corrupt they have a
little coup and the Scout's names are
cleared but Aaron Jaeger was captured
along with Krista why her Well turns out
her real name is Historia rice she's a
secret daughter of Lord rice who turns
out is the true royal family so Aaron's
chained up in a weird Crystal Cavern and
we actually finally get some answers the
royal family has the power of the
founding Titan or the coordinate which
lets them control other Titans that's
how the original King Fritz built the
walls a hundred years ago they're made
out of hardened Titans and the founding
Titan has another power in the hands of
the royal family it can alter the memory
of the people that's why no one
remembers any history from before 100
years ago the royal family has been
keeping them in Blissful ignorance so
for Generations this founding Titan has
been passed down through the Royal
bloodline you inject yourself with the
thing turn into a Titan eat your
ancestor and boom you're the new king
but five years ago Aaron's father Grisha
Yeager crashed the ceremony and somehow
he had the power to turn into a Titan
they had a Titan fight but Aaron's dad
won and ate the founding Titan taking
the power for himself then he injected
young Aaron who turned into a Titan and
ate his dad and now had the power of
both those Titans but why would he do
that we still don't know Lord rice makes
him out to be a bad guy and he's like
Historia you've got to turn into a Titan
eat your friend Aaron and get the
founding Titan back in the Royal
bloodline then you can use the power to
control all the other Titans and
Humanity will be freed so that sounds
nice time to save the world but Historia
realizes the hole in the story if the
royal family had this power for a
hundred years why did they never use it
to stop the Titans Well turns out along
with the founding Titan comes the
memories of the original King Fritz and
whoever gets it never explains why but
is like oh yeah now we gotta stay within
the walls so it becomes clear her dad
does not have Humanity's best interest
at heart he just wants to hold on to
power and his story is like oh hell nah
time to break the cycle and free
Humanity from the god King's rule
meanwhile Aaron's friends are coming to
rescue him they have an awesome flying
around fight versus Kenny and his crew
but now it does desperate Lord rice
licks the Titan potion which is not how
you're supposed to use it he turns into
a massive Titan Aaron and friends are
going to be crushed but Aaron found the
bottle gives Titan's hardening power and
eats it so boom yeah now he makes a hard
and Titan thing and saves them but Lord
rice has turned into such a big titan he
can't even walk he crawls his way to the
nearest Village and the Scout's gotta
fight him they ran some Gunpowder down
his throat and boom exploded so Historia
is crown queen but not bound to the will
of her ancestors and the day is saved
now with Aaron's new hardening power he
can theoretically patch up holes in the
wall so for the first time humanity has
a chance to patch up the holes in
Chicago and take back the outer ring the
scouts ride out in force and at first
the mission goes well but it was a trap
behind them a whole new crop of Titans
pop up led by the Beast Titan we briefly
get to meet him his name is Zeke and
he's run and bertolt's Commander and
Ryan is here too with the Armored Titan
but our Scouts have a surprise for him
hanji has invented Thunder Spears which
are basically rocket launchers which
boom blow through his armor but bear
told tier 2 with the power of the
Colossal Titan and the Beast Titans may
be the most dangerous he's a good
baseball player turns rocks into weapons
of mass destruction so commander Erwin
leads a suicide charge and almost all
the scouts are wiped out but that bought
time for Captain Levi to sneak around
the back and oh takes the Beast Titan
out now Lord rice had one more Titan
creating injection so if the Scouts can
capture one of the transforming Titans
alive they can take that power but Zeke
is rescued by another super weird Titan
who runs around on all fours they call
the cart Titan Our Gang blows up Rhino
but the cartine's there to rescue him
too and now it's Armin who has the
genius plan to take out the Colossal
Titan he goes him into using a steam
thing but he holds on until all
sacrificing himself but Armin figured
out using the steam burns away the
colossal's muscle mass and it bought
time for Aaron back in human form to
sneak up behind and oh get bear told and
Armin is still alive just barely it's
like hey give him the Titan injection so
it'll heal him and he can eat bear tilt
to get the Colossal but turns out
Commander Erwin is also barely alive and
Levi's got to choose which one to save
it becomes a heated debate but in the
end Levi chooses Aaron but with his last
breath Commander airwinds like now let
me die save the kid and so it's Armin
who's turned into a Titan eats bear told
and now has the power of the colossal
and so it's an epic victory for Humanity
they finally reclaimed their outer ring
but we still have no idea what's really
going on but now that they can get to
Aaron's old house in Chicago it's
finally time to find out what's in that
Cellar the mysterious key opens a secret
drawer which has books in it a book with
a photograph of Aaron's father and
another family this is weird because our
people don't have photograph technology
turns out they're not the last humans on
Earth there's a whole world out there
yes our Walt city is just on one little
island they're next to the Empire of
Marley which is at like early 1900s
technology that's where Aaron's father
is from but he's an aldian a race that
is horribly discriminated against forced
to wear armbands and living ghettos the
official story goes that Queen yamir of
the eldians made a deal with the devil
to get Titan powers and the old alien
Empire used the power of the nine Titans
that people can turn into to dominate
the world and they were awful and evil
but eventually there's a big war where
Marley got eight of the nine Titans and
defeated eldia so the alien king Fritz
fled with most of his people to the
island of parody Paradise where he used
the power of the founding Titan to build
the walls people's memories so they
could live in peace but many aliens were
left behind in Marley where now they're
treated terribly because of their devil
blood but when grishy Yeager's little
sister is killed by Marlene police he's
like oh hell no we aldians deserve
better he grows up and joins the
underground Elian resistance who
believes the official state history is a
lie they believe that Queen Amir and the
eldian Empire use the Titans for good
but we just don't know the truth now
it's here Grisham meets his first wife
who is a descendant of the Royal
bloodline that was left behind so they
have a dream if they can take back the
power of the founding Titan they can use
it to unleash the million Titans that
make up the walls and stop Marley to
dust and the LDN of Royal Blood who had
wield it is their son Zeke yes the Beast
Titan is Aaron's half-brother so
Marley's ignored parodies for a hundred
years but now they found out there's oil
there which is all the more important in
the modern world and Marley recruits
aliens into their army because they're
the only ones that can use the power of
the Titans that's who Ryan and bertilton
any were Elden warriors fighting for
Marley so Dr Grisha Yeager wasn't
doctrinating his young son Zeke you have
to pretend to be loyal to Marley so you
can become one of the alien Titan
Warriors but secretly you have to be
anti-marley steal the founding Titan and
use it to lead the Aldine Revolution
this was too much pressure for young and
he ended up turning his parents in
whoops criminal aliens are taking two
parodies where they're turned into
Titans so that's where the Titans are
coming from it's a punishment for them
and they serve as guards to keep the
island aldians inside their walls but
Grisha Yeager is saved by his guard who
turns out he's a secret Deli in the
resistance too and somehow through
unknown means he has the power of one of
the nine Titans it's the one Aaron gets
the attack Titan he's like hey man I
have the same basic plan as you but I
can't do it myself anyone who gets one
of the nine Titans only lives for 13
years and my time's almost up you gotta
take this one from me Infiltrate The
Walls steal the founding Titan and save
all aliens and so he did that's the
story we know and passed it on to a son
Aaron but wait a sec the founding Titan
only works if you have Royal Blood which
Aaron doesn't but Aaron figures out why
it worked that one time when he touched
the specific Titan because that Titan
was his dad's first wife who had the
Royal Blood so now we finally know
mostly what is going on and so
relatively quickly our humans finally
eradicate all the Titans on their Island
they are finally free except they're
kind of not though because right across
the sea is an entire world of people
that think they're devils and want to
kill them kind of a bummer and so season
four begins four years later over in
Marley we follow a new bunch of kids
they're the top Aldine Warrior
candidates to inherit one of the titans
the main ones are confident girl Gabby
and her friend Falco no Marley's at war
with someone and we get to see their
Titans in action by the way Emir was
executed they gave her Titan to a new
guy its proper name is the jaw Titan and
they use the normal mindless Titans pure
Titans As Weapons too for unknown
reasons probably related to his Royal
Blood Zeke has the power to transform
them with a yell and oh skydiving Titan
bombardment uh that should probably be a
war crime anyway as we get to know these
people we see they really aren't bad
most of these aliens think that fighting
for Marley is the right thing to do and
Rhino also who we've thought of as an
enemy but is a decent guy he and his
crew thought they were making their
country proud as they were shipped off
as kids on an undercover genocide
Mission anyway now with the recent War
one it's time to focus on parody again
they have a big event to announce
they're finally gonna go wipe out those
alien Devils but one of them is closer
than they think it's long-haired adult
Aaron Jaeger he and Ryan have a chat
it's like I'm so sorry man and Air is
like yeah I understand and I'm sorry too
because Aaron's here on his own mission
oh Titan attack most of the Marlene High
command is gathered right there so Aaron
takes them out in one Fell Swoop but a
Titan Warrior we haven't met yet is here
to fight back they call it the Warhammer
Titan because it can use its hardening
power to like make up Hammer but Aaron's
not alone mikas is here too with a whole
bunch of Thunder Spears boom Aaron eats
that girl and takes the power of the
Warhammer Titan now too yes a bunch of
Scouts are here ready to fight in the
modern world it's a massive fight all
the Marley Titans join in but our crew
with their odm gear are deadly but now
Mika says like Aaron what have you done
you just killed thousands of civilians
and our new kid Gabby having seen a
bunch of her friends die swears
Vengeance just like Aaron did all those
years ago our crew escapes on their new
Airship but Gabby's not letting him get
away she and Falco get aboard and shoots
the first person she sees which is no
not Sasha she was so nice just love to
eat anyway turns out this preemptive
attack was just Aaron Yeager's idea the
military told him not to but him
starting it forced their hand and Aaron
had a co-conspirator his half-brother
Zeke going back a few years to see how
he got here are people captured one of
the Marlene Scout chips that the tall
girl in command here is like hey we're
part of the LDN resistance against
Marley we want to be friends and believe
it or not Zeke the Beast Titan is with
us too so they helped our wall people
get modern technology and meet some
allies out in the world this country was
allies with the old Albion Empire and
turns out their Queen went behind the
walls too and it's Mika says ancestor so
she's a princess and speaking of
princesses in case it matters Historia
is pregnant the plan was supposed to be
to reintroduce themselves to the world
in a peaceful manner hey we aren't
Devils but Darren Yeager apparently
disagreed he doesn't talk much anymore
to actually explain himself but it seems
like he believed the only way they'll
ever really be safe is if they wipe out
everyone else most of the military
including Aaron's friends all think this
attack was a bad idea but there's a lot
of them who think that Aaron had the
right of it and are ready to conquer the
world as the new alien Empire and soon
Aaron breaks himself out of prison to
lead this group called The jaegerists
and Aaron Yeager has grown up from an
annoying angry yelling kid to a badass
Stone Cold Rebel leader so the jagerists
take over the government and Aaron
finally talks to his friends who are
like what the heck are you doing man but
Aaron still doesn't explain his
motivations he is really mean to his
friends though makes Mika I time will
tell if Aaron has really become such a
douchebag or if he has some secret plot
we know the first part of his plan
though is to meet up with Zeke who's
being held prisoner in the forest by
Captain Levi and a whole Squad of
soldiers we learned that it's Zeke's
spinal fluid that if ldans ingest it he
can turn him into Titans somewhat under
his control and turns out the wine his
friends brought from Marley were spiked
with his juices so now he shouts and
turns all his guards into Titans but not
Captain Levi he doesn't drink and
handily takes down the Beast Titan again
he ties him to a thunder Spear and makes
him explain his double-double cross
super secret plan Zeke's Mentor was the
Beast Titan before him who knew all
about Titan lore and he learned the
founding Titan with royal blood can do
more than alter eldian memories it can
alter their physiology so Zeke who
witnessed all the alien suffering
doesn't agree with his dad that they
should rise up he thinks it would be
best if they just disappeared apparently
his real plan is to take the founding
Titan and use it to sterilize all aliens
so they and Titans will disappear from
the earth for now though he escapes by
blowing himself up along with Captain
Levi who will hopefully be fine Zeke's
Titan Powers will eventually heal him
and he escapes once again now back in
the city Marley airships are here for
their counter-attack and leading the
assault is our old friend rhina who is
the Armored Titan and he and Aaron have
an epic rematch Zeke's Titan healing
kicks in and the Beast Titan joins the
battle but remember he's fighting
against Marley now his goal is to touch
Aaron so he can go through with his LDN
sterilization plan but if these two
touch they could also use the founding
Titan's power to unleash the million
Titans that make up the walls and
destroy the world in an event called the
rumbling so Molly's main goal is not to
let that happen they blast Zeke to take
him out but he's not dead so now he has
to play his trump card he screams
transforming all the parody zeldians
that drink the wine spiked with a spinal
fluid into Titans they were Rampage on
the marlian forces and for the first
time since the early Seasons we've got a
Titan attack now remember little Falco
accidentally drank some of the wine so
he's a Titan too now and rushes over to
attack Reina but way twos this come to
sacrifice himself to save Reina it's
their other friend who has the jot Titan
and oh now Falco eats him got the power
of the jaw so now Ryan continues to beat
up Baron but Aaron Yeager pulls a trick
he hardens to trap Ryan there then
leaves his body and makes a run for it
because Zeke is still alive and he's
gonna touch him but now who's this it's
little gobby with a sniper rifle boom
wow she blows Aaron's head clean off but
if there's one thing we know about Zeke
he loves playing baseball and he makes
the diving catch and Aaron's brain was
just alive enough they've successfully
done it they are in the coordinate of
all eldians with their founder Emir now
at first Zeke is chained up it's like
Aaron actually you have a power here and
Aaron's like well psych bro I'm not
doing your plan I'm doing my own plan
but now Zeke is like yo double psych I
was just pretending to not have power
here so you would reveal your true
intentions long story short they go on a
journey through the memories of their
father Grisha Jaeger and turns out he
didn't go through with his plan to kill
the royal family and steal the founding
Titan because you know it would involve
massacring these kids but then Aaron
Jaeger starts talking to his father who
can hear him it's like what's up Dad I'm
the spirit of your son from the future
here to tell you you gotta go through
with it trust me so somehow it was Aaron
Jaeger himself who started this whole
adventure to get to this present moment
because now it's like triple psych bro I
actually actually do somehow have the
power here so now Zeke tells a mirror to
sterilize all the aliens and Aaron goes
over to stop her and this whole series
it's been a mystery who actually was a
mirror and how did she end up with Titan
power turns out to me or wasn't eldian
herself she was a slave of the aliens
who were confirmed to terrible people
somehow she fell into this water with a
weird jellyfish vertebrae thing that
thou turned her into the first Titan but
Amir spent her whole life as a slave she
only knew obedience to the LD and King
Fritz and so used her Titan powers to
join his army and help conquer the world
in fact she had King Fritz's children
and one day sacrificed herself to save
him to keep the Titan power they had her
children eat her and that's how we got
the nine Titans so now Aaron grabs her
like yo it's time to stop being a slave
it's time for you to fight back and
she's like you know what bro you're
right so somehow she passes the founding
Titan power to Aaron and now we realize
Aaron's true plan is not to threaten the
rumbling to keep Marley away but to
unleash it right now yes the walls are
coming down a million colossal Titans
headed to the mainland the rumbling is
here as for Aaron himself he transforms
into the biggest Titan yet and we don't
get a full shot of it but it's
apparently a weird slithering thing and
now Aaron psychically talks to all the
aldians like hey what's up guys it's
like look the outside world hates us and
that's just not gonna change the only
way my home the island of parodies can
ever really be safe is if we wipe out
every other person on the planet and
yeah I mean that's obviously awful but
it's rough because he's kind of right so
the rumbling is happening and doesn't
look like anyone can stop it remember in
part one of the season the jagerists let
a coup to take over parodies they're led
by this red-haired guy flock and they're
all real happy they're like yeah we can
live in peace and restart life on Earth
but unfortunately he's got kind of a
dictator Vibe and executes anyone not on
his side this leaves any Marley and
survivors like Peak the cart Titan as
enemies of the state and also enemies of
the state our commander hanji and an
injured but alive Captain Levi it's like
yo we're not with the jagerists let's be
allies John seems like he's sided with
the agarists but when they bust on in
there oh they eat him but actually it
was a rescue he was working with them
and all of Aaron's friends are in on the
plan and they recruit another old friend
it's Annie yeah when Aaron took down the
Walls he undid all hardened Titans
including her shell so for almost the
whole series she's been sitting there in
the basement but now Annie is back and
so all our main characters are on the
same side it's been complicated as
everyone's had different motivations to
fight at different times but now they
all agree killing everyone in the world
is not the right move they gotta stop
Aaron and they have a plan they figure
they can catch up to Aaron by using the
flying boats aka the plane that mikasa's
relatives the osmobito family brought
but the Icarus are guarding it but Annie
and Rhino bust in and transform yes the
female Titan back in action with the
armored and weirdly now they're on our
side even with the Titans on our side
our crews now winning the jagerists and
perfected the art of Titan fighting so
it's time for young Falco to go on in
help and broom he transforms to the jaw
Titan uh his versions Harry for some
reason so it's an epic battle at the
Port as our crew fights the jaegerists
but it's not really try jump into like
back when they were killing Titans
because these friends are jagerists
aren't even bad they're just on
different sides and everyone's doing
what they gotta do to survive in the end
flock tries to take out the ship so they
can't get to air in but oh someone
shoots him and he was the hero in his
own story but unfortunately not in this
one turns out the plane's not ready to
fly so they gotta tow it to the mainland
where they can repair it then hopefully
catch up with Aaron in the rumbling but
the question is how are they gonna stop
Aaron he's still our crew's best friend
they hope they can just talk him out of
it but everyone else is skeptical and
now off the marlian coast the entire
world has banded together gotten all the
guns they have but it's not enough the
fleet is quickly obliterated and now the
rumbling Titans ready to Stomp the world
flat and as if that weren't enough right
behind him they've got Aaron's massive
new Titan body that we still don't get
like a full look at but I mean it looks
weird how will this story come to an end
find out in Attack on Titan season 4
part 3 which is allegedly actual the
real final final part but it will be
itself split up into two parts
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
foreign